solve it what's up everyone welcome to
simulation how's it going today we have
a very exciting episode we're gonna be
featuring dr. Jordans slave yeah look at
that
what oh here we go thank you for coming
out of the show
sure thanks for having me yeah we first
met like two years ago at this really
interesting dinner that you were
throwing with Jamie Haywood and you guys
were taking blood pre dinner and posting
her and analyzing like what happens well
yeah there was really good wine in the
middle so it's what what does really
good wine do to the physiology of the
body we know what it does to the liver
but a lot of other biomarkers out there
yeah and this was you know this was two
years ago I was you know I was first
just you know little kid 23 years old
I'm still a little kid still no nothing
buddy much yeah yeah and I mean when I
was there I really felt very blessed to
be there there were some very big game
changers in that room that are working
on on the on the forefront on the edge
of what's known in measuring biomarkers
and leveraging machine learning to
figure out predictions and health I'm in
Prevention's and disease for me I mean
this is all like super important for
longevity and super important for health
and I was just blown away that you guys
were doing that and and having fun and
having I mean if you're not having fun
what are you doing I think I think
there's so much gravity around health
care of you I mean there's a lot of
excitement but it's it's a serious you
know trade people's lives you know
there's a lot of excitement about what
what the future could be but you know
when you're in the middle of it it's
it's it's you know you're dealing with
people that think they have cancer or do
have cancer or broke their leg or it's
almost got arthritis and you know
someone's really sick and and that's
like the the daily stuff and so you know
to make sure there's levity amongst the
gravity you know it is is I think humor
is is the I mean we I wish I could write
a prescription for it because I think it
does lighten the stress on oneself which
then
probably helps the immune system heal
oneself so I again yeah it's not an
exact science but it's just
pattern recognition over time yeah and
these are the things that are very
difficult to measure is I mean we see
cortisol affecting health quite a bit
but who measures laughter and happen
overall like just happiness like vibing
with life on health so okay so this
started at Berkeley with physiology did
how did you even know that you wanted to
get into health oh yeah how did I know
that's very Kretz a question you're
probably throw all day to me my father
son of an immigrant of grew up in
Detroit he his dad told him you will be
a doctor kind of whatever immigrant
parent wants their kid to be and so my
dad became a doctor in and then he moved
out to California about my mom or
they're both from Detroit and my mom was
at Berkeley my dad was doing a residency
out here at UCSF for and they had me and
my father said to me everything you can
be whatever you want when you grow up as
long as you're a doctor so that was like
a steady diet of that my whole life so I
was like I guess I'm gonna be doctor and
I was like pre-med while I was in middle
school you know and and I didn't know it
like it was I wouldn't call brainwashing
but maybe I would but I was fascinated
by his life he had a very very smart guy
but he seemed to love what he did he
could kind of set his own schedule he
was helping people
he made decent money yeah you know and
it was like yep I like those things in
life like I kind of like saw his life as
he wasn't grinding you know when the
pager went off in the middle of night
and he was gonna go save somebody's life
like he yes he loved it I meant all so
he was the guy that would show up like
take that case that nobody wanted at
3:00 in the morning with the infected
bowels and then go in there and do an 8
9 hour he'd come home with like blood
splatters on his glasses and you know
exhausted and tell us all about it great
so I just had a lot of a lot of modeling
around it so yeah anyway off I went to
Berkeley and
anatomy and physiology were interesting
and there was a teacher there Marian
diamond who was the I think she's still
around but she was like this guru
anatomy teacher if you could get her so
I was kind of drawn to that because of
her usually teachers make the difference
and and then was just off to the races
you know I loved it and and I was
applying to medical school and I'm in
along the way here yeah so first of all
crazy cool dad and like family and you
know it can be it can be overwhelming at
times for a kid to just be pre-med in
middle school because but at the same
time it's also very rewarding to have
conversations at the dinner table about
a father that takes the pager and paging
that's happening in the middle of the
night and runs out and goes and helps
save someone's life and comes back and
teaches at the dinner table about what
what's going on I mean that is so
rewarding that's like a really an
amazing experience that I hope so many
other kids don't get to hear about and
have in their lives
and unfortunately medicines like become
a pretty hellish place right now for
doctors so I don't think a lot of
doctors are coming home to their kids
and bringing anything forward that
resembles joy I mean I hope it does but
there's it's it's it is like a it is a
shitshow out there in medicine right now
and is not as it is not getting better
and we can talk about that yeah at a
macro economic level and why but yes we
will we're gonna unpack that okay so
that's so important is how do we make
the health care system actually function
more optimally for families and for for
actual health yeah okay so let's talk
about the step to the what you
experience was when you went to Kenya
this is interesting
teach us about this so story of my life
kind of happenstance and serendipity
come together as ingredients and then
things happen to me or I happen to them
I don't know but I was at a graduation
party at Berkeley I met this woman at a
bar we were having some friends and she
said really you're gonna go to medical
school right after Berkeley didn't you
do summer school to take your MCATs last
year and did
summer school the year before that to do
biochemistry and didn't you do summer
school they've River let's do organic
chemistry and I said yeah I did you go
so you had four years of college was no
summer I said yeah but I got good grades
and my strategy was take the hardest
class I was I have to take the next year
during the summer and just take one
class and like have a kind of you know
you can get an A in the summer if you're
in one class but then the next year I
could take history and philosophy or
something music because everyone else
had to take that really hard class and
it really amongst all the other classes
so this girl says well you should take a
year off and you should go I was like
what like that'd never I was already
applied to medical schools like I was
like I was launched like this has been
my plan forever and my father's plan
forever and so she wrote down a phone
number this is pre cell phone
pre-internet days you know this is night
circa 1989 she wrote down a number I put
in my pocket and the next morning I woke
up and I'm like huh and call this number
you know it wasn't 867-5309 by the way
and it was understand we place on
reference we you just played that song
in our band the other night so it's kind
of in my head
and it was this program at Harvard
called world teach and I was like and
they said I said yeah I'm inquiring
about what you guys do and they said
well we we put teachers and countries
all around the world and they said by
the way the deadline to apply is today
and we don't need any more English
teachers and I said oh well I'm actually
probably not a good English teacher like
I can't spell I'm not gonna you know my
grammar sucks and I said but I know
science better than anybody know and and
they're like oh really we don't have any
science teachers and they said can you
teach chemistry I'm like sure increase
physics sure can you teach biology sure
they said hold on a second and so
literally they connected me with
somebody at Berkeley who is a Harvard
alumni of this organization world teach
and I had an interview locally and the
next thing you know I was doing my after
college Eurail pass and I was in
Florence and I called my mom to see if I
got it accepted to this program she goes
you got accepted to Georgetown Medical
School and you got accepted to world
teach and world teach said you could go
to Kenya Costa Rica or China to teach
where would you like to go
so we're sitting at the piadmin option -
mm-hmm
science teachers were into manse I was
at the Piazza - Michelangelo above
overlooking Florence and I like I was
being a little campgrounds elevating
your next life decision yeah and I was
like huh so I immediately called
Georgetown and I said can you take my
acceptance out and give it to me next
year can you defer my acceptance for a
year and they're like sure that's the
easiest ition we can make because now we
can give somebody else who's really
qualified at that spot so I deferred and
then I picked Kenya and the next thing
you know I came back home got my
immunizations and wound up in a town
called khattala which is a old colonial
town and I did eight weeks of eight
hours a day you were learning Swahili
you will be teaching in Swahili whoa I
was like whoa okay and it was like a
super jarring moment of existence
because I here I was at Berkeley in the
trenches studying and then I was in
Europe doing Mike you know visiting
countries and seeing things I never seen
before and then I'm in like rural no
electricity no running water no vehicles
high on a plateau thrown into a school
with like the windows are just there's
no glass there just cutouts like
buildings with you know and and I was
the only white guy and the little kids
who had never seen a white person before
were lady they'd run up and want to
touch me and so it was like a real whoa
moment of existence but I learned a ton
yeah being there and one of the major
aha moments that I had yes there's a
probably two or three but this was the
big one is I'd been you know you had to
you know you've seen the women with the
big urns that they walk around so I was
like really far in a plateau Lily far
from anything but we overlooked Lake
Victoria and it was a beautiful stunning
and these women would climb down this
cliff that was probably five meters of
rocky jaggedy and there was a little
water that came out the side of it
they'd fill up the urns put him on their
head and climb back up with kids and
goats and like I don't know how they did
it but they've been doing it for
probably a thousand years right and
that's how they get their water and and
I of course needed water to brush my
teeth and make my coffee and make my
rice because I you know I had like a
fool trying to do that at your first
well I well I was like okay first
kind of like rocky and perilous you know
it's not like like a path you know and
so I did it and I'd fill up my things
and I was just like one of the like I
wanted to really blend in and not I mean
I'm the white guy with crazy blonde hair
like I didn't really blend in but but I
wanted to like really immerse myself in
the way they did it I didn't want to be
above it you know and do things the
Western Way and so about six months into
my stay there I woke up one morning you
know and by the way you wake up when the
Sun comes up because that's your light
like when Sun Goes Down there's no light
it's like dark you have to have a little
you have a candle with lard and it cost
money and no not everybody had candles
you know so when it was dark so much
people sitting in a room talking you
know and you couldn't see anybody it was
like it was like human radio ears yes it
wasn't even fires so one day I heard all
his noise kind of off in the distance
and a bunch of people talking and kind
of as it was pretty dawn I looked out I
saw all these moms lined up you know
over the but probably about 40 meters
away it's pretty far so I walk over
there and someone had and I got on the
other property put a spigot with a you
know a hose not a hose but just a water
faucet and they had somehow found it
well pumped water like and apparently
this had been in the works for like a
decade we're gonna get water to the
plateau you know that that's that's yeah
mechanical hydro whatever and so these
people like we're like fascinated like
all of a sudden they'd have to climb
down the thing and so all the women
lined up pre-dawn with their kids and it
was like 100 of them and they would take
their urns and fill it up and so then I
was like huh that's better so then I
would walk over and I all I wanted was
like in the morning I wanna brush my
teeth so I would just walk up to the
front of the line with just a cup and I
would say can I fill my water up and I
was the teacher in town I was helping
the kids so I was like I had like the
most favored nation status there's a lot
of tribal stuff that goes on in those
villages like in fighting and like tons
of drama tons of tons of tons of drama
and which another story I've got a bunch
of stories that a voodoo curse put on me
eventually as anyway so the purpose of -
yeah that's a whole other story so I was
in line
and I would go there every morning and I
felt my cup and I you know I didn't had
my coffee yet I hadn't like really I
wasn't awake you know I just walk out
there I want to brush my teeth and I
gonna use the rest make some water
coffee and I realized that the water
wasn't coming out of the spigot very
fast and I and I and I realized that
these people had never seen a spigot
before and what I thought was I wondered
if when they walked up to and they
turned it on and water came out they
were so happy that they didn't realize
that if they continued to turn it it
would come out faster so I asked the
woman in Swahili up I'm like hey dude
like I'm thinking aha I'm gonna show
them so you know show them something in
fact I taught them how to make french
fries up they're like caught a potato
and boil it like they'd never seen
french fries anyway done their story
probably a bad thing by the way
introducing french fries but I said to
the woman and I showed her I said let me
show you something and I turned the
thing and water came way out faster at
me and like all the women like that
we're in the front of the line kind of
backed up look whoa and other women were
too busy chatting and and I'm smiling
I'm like kind of cool huh and this woman
looked at me and she had big gap teeth
in the you know it was dark it was like
pre-dawn and she looking with his big
smile that I'll never forget
and she put it right back to where it
was and she said what's the rush and I a
moment of significant cognitive
dissonance for me I'm like huh and and
and then I grab my cup and I kind of
walked back into my my little Hut that I
was living in and I was thinking like
holy smokes like this water represents
work they're gonna clean the house
they're gonna cook they're gonna they're
gonna wash dishes they're gonna wash
clothes and when the water goes slow
this is the only time these women get
together and hang out this is social
hour this is about community it's about
people and humanity and dignity and
laughter and and that work is water you
you get home with your water you're
working it's it just it's all work maybe
food so cooking but then you get to eat
it but so I realized that you know this
Western idea idea of efficiency like
efficiency is the most important thing
so I walked away with okay at some point
efficiency decays diminishes is
corrosive to quality at a high level in
just human interaction so icon on
various social media platforms you can
be very efficient with your
communication but are you losing are you
losing something and you are and what is
it and like how do you like in it these
things are soft and they're not obvious
and so we are with generally because we
can't measure them we don't and we just
write them off but like I think what
we're seeing in the world today is we've
become so efficient at so many things
that we just want robots to do it for us
now and and and people are becoming more
lonely depressed like because they're
because humanity and dignity and and all
the things that make humans human is we
need other humans and and humans aren't
efficient factor the opposite of
efficient you know but but they're high
quality so trying to anyway so so I took
that lesson and made sure that whatever
I did I'd pay attention to the
efficiency quality ratio and what am I
not seeing as I'm becoming efficient
that where's the quality so I I look for
things that are hard to find and these
very subtle nuanced things that that I
believe eventually will will become
obvious but they're so until they become
obvious that it's just like a flip
switches one day and you're like why did
that happen
but you could have seen it happening if
you were really paying attention so that
was my big aha moment and I've kind of
taken that philosophy or that
perspective through everything that I do
I love that what's the rush what's the
rush and I can feel what it could have
felt like being across from her when you
did that
uh-huh and she was like what's the rush
but you put it right back right yeah I
was like whoa this is time for us to be
a community here right now
and we we they knew more about the
efficiency quality ratio then than the
Western world in its well I think
there's a natural state of humans that
understands what quality is I think
there's also a natural curiosity like I
think animals are as efficient as they
can be in what they do because they have
to like it's how they exist like that to
be efficient with safety they have to be
efficient with food there but there's a
different kind of efficiency in the
animal world but they're super efficient
they figured it out over generations
humans have this thing called curiosity
and humans have this ability to envision
multiple potential futures right and and
as a result of this curiosity the
ability to have hold in your head
multiple versions of the future what we
do is we think oh my god we should get
that that that would be cool like and
all this whole technology here we aren't
Silicon Valley's amateurs but everyone's
with robotics and blockchain and I oh my
god it's just gonna be better because
it's more efficient and and it's like
you know we are deluding ourselves and
diluting ourselves with this concept
that all this stuff's gonna make things
better and I was having a really
interesting conversation last night with
a bunch of moms and dads and my daughter
graduated eighth grade and and we were
talking about how you know you know how
hard middle school is for kids and how
like the kids getting these arguments
and parents want to get in and and like
medal and their kids affairs and like I
got this one text from a mom saying your
daughter said this to my son and you
need to like I got that I got a year ago
and I looked at it I delete like that
like I'm not gonna metal in my like and
so I said you know I bet if we looked at
over the course of a thousand
generations of humans so we can't write
we can only look at our eighth grade
snare like but I said do you know what
you're I have barely remember with my
apron what did your daughter say to the
kid what what did your daughter say to
the kid oh it was like someone had
accused my daughter of saying that some
girl was you know flirting with a guy I
mean it was like a nothing thing okay
but the mom didn't want her some rumor
going around that her daughter was like
a flirt it was like as
Nate as it gets right and I was like I
am NOT gonna meddle in my daughter's
affairs she has to learn this stuff
that's I mean resiliency and coping
skills are think yeah life is about
other humans and until it's all about
robots but you know for the short term I
think it's about other humans and so you
know you have to learn how to deal with
them and and humans are uniquely capable
and of envisioning multiple potential
futures so when I'm dialoguing with you
there was another thing that you
unpacked there that was really important
was that we think that just all these
exponential technologies that are
proliferating are going to make things
so much better we're not considering the
quality of these present moments that we
have with each other to the fullest we
were not augmenting how to have these
present moments that's why we know many
crazy well complications yeah and and
and I'll get back to this concept of the
multiple generations but as I in my
musings like the denominator of humanity
the functional unit the fundamental
element of humanity is a conversation
that's all we do all day long
and whether we think that that's not
true go ahead and stop don't don't
communicate with anybody for a day see
how that goes I mean that's like silent
retreats and people do that but those
are fantastic and they're fantastic and
but they're good because you don't have
that in the real world it's like an it's
like a thing you know the people that
can do that right but if you go to
Africa they have a solitude moments all
the time like that's normal
we've jam-packed our [ __ ] up with so
much stuff that we need that as like a
whoa it's so great it's like no you're
just way off balance if you have to go
have a silent retreat for a week that
means like the rest of your life is like
it's like people say do you work out I'm
like yeah I you know but my work out is
I just as I exist in the world I'm
always kind of moving i've standup desks
i I don't do the one hour of hard cardio
be like to me it's like why not have a
whole day of like light exercise which
is as good for you dancing and stretch
just walking and you know if I have a
meeting let's walk around the block
let's not sit in the desk and so I just
I feel like everyone's trying to like
find the thing that they're missing and
the thing that they're missing is is
they're not paying attention to like
they're filling their plate with things
that are shiny objects and they're
trying to pack it all in and FOMO and
and there's reasons for that because
we're curious
see all these things two things two
things what first thing is Aubrey de
Grey calls the cell phone the ultimate
destroyer of human solitude that's
really interesting and he's the only
person I know that doesn't have a cell
phone and then the other thing was that
Junoon taught us about opportunity
obesity how we are just FOMO is is one
of the main things and then also just
similar to food obesity now there's so
much opportunity we don't even know how
to apply the peretta distribution to our
opportunity to figure out that only 20%
of those opportunities are gonna produce
80% of the value that we can provide
them they can provide us it's cetera
yeah so so I just wanted to you know to
throw those what you were going yeah no
and and and so going back to this just
to go zoom way out as I said you know I
bet if if you looked at my sixth grade
to eighth grade and then I could look at
my parents yes my grandma and my
grandparents like I have no idea what my
grandparents growing up was like I
couldn't even fathom like it's in black
and white and it's in some other country
and you know they're making goulash in
the morning and like I don't know and
laying in the courtyard and then go back
a hundred generations mm-hmm try it in
your head we don't have the capacity
capacity to do that really to go back
100 generations and try to imagine what
life was like for kids in school like
3,000 years yeah or like yeah when there
was like you that you teach and you know
I bet all the issues that are happening
in my 8th grade school have happened
forever like kids get in fights they
learn how to live with each other but
because we can't think of that and we
only think of what's in front of us and
like this is the most like like somehow
this is unique like no it's not this
isn't going on forever but it's more
than unique because of the information
technologies that exists in it that's
true but I think just the experience of
a kid growing up with other kids yes has
always been dealt fraught with does he
like me is he mad at me are you flirting
with me I mean it's it's bait there's
like basic blocks of humanity building
blocks if you man totally right and you
just like you said the conversation
that's what we do right and I think that
the the guinness of conversations are
the fundamental unit the glue that
connects these units together as Trust
mm-hmm and and so when you unpack trust
and I spend a lot of time thinking about
trust because you know I say when you
wake up in the morning what's the first
thing you do right well you you you
realize you're awake
like the first thing you do when you
wake up is you go I'm not okay Here I am
like I'm in bed I haven't done anything
except for realized it right you know if
you get into that granular level that
one then you move you get up and you
start moving and where do you start
moving in your day like some people go
to the bathroom some people brush their
teeth some people go sir to get coffee
wear wear whatever you do you trust like
we move in the direction of trust we
communicate to things that are
trustworthy like we don't go to if
somebody doesn't go into some jackass
liar bad guy you're not gonna go and
that's that's gonna be a repellant so
it's not gonna be an attractant our
algorithms guide us towards things that
we trust and towards things that we know
are producing the there's a fidelity to
it there's a predictability to it
there's a reliability to it it's if that
happens over and over oh I trust it it
has shown me that it's trustworthy but
that's like your toothbrush it always
works or brushing your teeth I trust my
toothbrush like I know I'm not gonna get
there no spiders gonna like it's gonna
turn into a spider and like you bite me
like that's not gonna happen
yeah that's why you're always very
relaxed when you're doing that rather
than you have to be but when you get in
front of another human like all bets are
off you know nothing even the person
that you know really well you like this
is true I tell people like look it's
hard enough to know like anybody but you
don't even know who you are
sure like and so how you gonna know
anybody else and and so the interesting
thing is so Ivan drive about what is
trust and I to me at a level of the kind
of the humanist in me is you trust
people in all we do is communicate with
people and I'm getting not to the things
that we trust if they value you and if
they include you and if you have both of
those things you will get trust yeah if
you only have one of them
you still have some trust so there was a
study done at Harvard awhile back about
harassment in the workplace and let's
let's keep this quick because I have so
much yeah yeah yeah and basically what
it said is that you know people who are
harassed by their boss like verbally
abused and or those that are ignored
which which is worse it's the ones that
are ignored which means that if you're
abused verbally you're at least included
you're not valued but you're included
but when you're not valued or include it
hurts more yes anyway yeah so I do think
that that trust and communication is is
the name of the game for people and
everything else is is is filigree yeah
that's good yeah and that's why you care
about linguistics as well it works and
yeah actually George as if was one of
the first ones that introduced me to the
predator distribution the way that
linguistics works okay yeah all right so
that's been insanely cool first chunk of
time the program I feel like we have
stuff so much just there to unpack whole
episode on just that ok let's move on
let's move on sure ok so moving on we
move to to Georgetown how did you how
did you kind of figure out exactly what
like how did you go from Georgetown to
the private medical like so Georgetown
was great I had never lived in the other
side of the country I actually went
there because I wanted to live in the
East Coast because I'm from California
went to Berkeley you know I didn't owe
anything other than California
I came so I actually wanted to I thought
I thought I wanted to be a hand surgeon
at first though they come microvascular
hand surgeon that's where I think set my
sights on and but and so I then I
thought you know video games were just
starting to collect nintendo's and
television and stuff like that and so I
thought well maybe I'll do
interventional radiology where you
actually have joysticks and you're
threading vessels to be you know I'm
like okay I'll do interventional
radiology that's like I was a video game
freak and I was computer like I learned
how do you do computers in the 80s when
the Apple 2 came out I said dad I want
to figure this stuff out other into the
program and so I kind of always been
kind of a technophile like interested in
it and so I did one year of residency
you have to do before you if I matched
in Boston at Boston Newman Medical
Center to do interventional radiology
and and you come out to do one year of
medicine general medicine before you dig
into your specialist I was out here at
doing my one year of Jemison in San
Francisco where my father was the chief
of surgery and all my friends were here
and was beautiful weather in Boston it
was like freezing cold and you know and
I was like you know what I am gonna stay
here and do internal medicine then you
get to be a healer you get to be a
doctor of the people and it just it just
feels better for me I'm more of a people
person so I decide my program hey can I
just stay here and do that so I did that
and it was right around the time of HMOs
were eating the world and when HMOs ate
the world just hmm sorry I know I don't
use algorithms
I mean acronyms in general health
maintenance organizations were the first
way of how do we do cost containment and
really what they did is they basically
changed the way doctors were paid and
and and it was like you know it was like
the little fish eating the bigger fish
was a bigger fish like eating a little
fish and so these doctors were getting
put into these bigger groups these
bigger news had better more purchasing
power to negotiate contracts with the
big payers and it was like the beginning
of like one version of something that
didn't work but as that was going
doctors were getting paid less and
patients were being had told that a
gatekeeper now and the first kind of
universe of doctors were at gatekeepers
versus healers like who wants to be a
gatekeeper like that's not what I went
into medical school to be right no you
can't have that treatment because it
cost too much like why am i doing that
anyway so as that was in full swing and
as I was graduating my residency here in
San Francisco
the HMO of the big one called brown and
Toland in town was being sued by the
federal government the Federal Trade
Commission on antitrust they had too
many doctors in this one group that they
were monopolies in San Francisco they
had too many covered lives so like no
other competitors could could compete
with this group they would they'd gotten
all the doctors so they were not and
then in urination would get like a taxi
medallion now that you have this HMO you
can take these insurances and get all
these patients so I couldn't get into
that group because they had put a freeze
on hiring any new doctors because of
this Federal Trade Commission lawsuit so
I was like
damn damn so I got job offers in Fresno
and Modesto and Bakersfield great places
and I was like nothing wrong with those
places but like my family's here my
friends are here like my life has been
here all my life like no so it turns out
there's old guy right on the street here
on 180 Montgomery Montgomery impost and
he was like this 80 year old doc
well-established blue chip talker he had
left the hospital to go downtown the
financial district he took care of the
charles schwab z' of the world the
employer is not him himself but the
front of the banker is in them so he
said to me hey come work with me for a
year I'm gonna retire you can have the
whole practice when I retire the
conditions are you're gonna be on call
365 days for one year I'm gonna take a
week off a month and and I'm not gonna
pay very much and you're gonna cover for
me the week I'm off I'm like if if I do
that for a year and you retire then this
whole office with the views and all the
staff and all the patients and the HMO
medallion and then like I'm in so I
worked my ass off but off for a year I
live nearby on Telegraph Hill so I
walked to work it was great
and I'm month 11 he said it's time I
said I said you know let's let's start
you know yeah we got to get the
transition plan going and you know long
story short is he basically said you
know I really like this arrangement
let's do this I'll pay you more I'll you
know give you I'm like no dude like all
I got is my reputation and my word yeah
you told me I have a signed document we
have to find a way for you to start
training he's like I'm just not ready to
retire I'm like are you telling me
you're not gonna do no so I packed up my
cell flight and I I'm out of here I quit
I just walked out I had no plan
and I was like aside on the street I'm
like holy [ __ ] what I just do you're out
on a job all right
paid the rent you know he wasn't paying
that much anyway so I walked into a
little cafe down the street on you know
I was like totally days ordered a cup of
tea and and I realized where am i I
looked around and I got a hotel lobby
and a cafe and a fancy hotel though and
I was like a five-star hotel and like
there's a concierge desk and all these
fancy people are coming and going and I
just kind of like you know that left my
universe and went into the universe of
hospitality like I sometimes just leave
my universe and go into another universe
and then I was like people get sick here
at this
I walked up to the concierge desk and I
said excuse me who is the doctor you
call when somebody gets sick here really
and she looks at me she was who are you
and I said well I could be the doctor
you call when somebody gets sicker she
was your doctor I said I'm a doctor
she goes look there's a five-star hotel
it's the only five-star hotel in Center
just go at the time it was the Mandarin
she said everything we do here is
five-star service she said I'm just a
concierge and I may be one star smart
but everything we do here's five stars
lunches linens limos perfect like my
guess we have to give them the best all
the time she said you're probably five
star smart cuz you're a doctor and you
went to medical school but you're
industry's one star service you don't
care about service so if you want to be
the house doctor for my hotel took a lot
of ownership she goes you need to learn
five-star service or you have to deliver
five-star service so I looked at her can
you teach me what that means to you
like I've never been I mean I've been
with hospitals not hospitality right and
so she said well and make sure you're a
doctor first so she credential she
called the hospital like I put papers in
front of her showing her I was like on
the medical society board and blah blah
blah and so the next thing I was seeing
patients that were like running the like
senators and governors and NBA players
and movie stars and prime ministers that
would fly in and and so I had this weird
window and she's like look there's
one-pagers no cellphones
well they cell phones had just come out
so I was the first person to give I so I
gave them my email my pager and my cell
phone and I was texting back in the late
90s and before it really was a thing and
so she loved the fact that I could be
there in five minutes and I could take
care of the guests and I would follow up
and so I kind of learned what it's which
is basic common sense dignity decorum
like five-star services a lot of it's
like just paying attention in
self-reflection and trying to you know
empathy and stuff like that so the next
thing you know I was the doctor to the
Mandarin and it was like people would
gladly pay me a couple hundred dollars
in cash for the value that I delivered I
came to their house when their hotel
room when they were sick and I
contrasted that when when I was in that
doctor's office people would like hold
on to their five dollar copay and like
God like just absolutely not want to pay
you the five dollar copay or theirs and
I was like why do people not want to
give you five it's five bucks these
people have plenty of money but those
people are happy to give you 200 for the
house call
five hundred whatever it's because the
five dollars they didn't see the value
in it like they didn't see the value in
this whole thing the whole show Edison
which is zero service good smarts if
people didn't really want to be there so
why would they give money for it so so
then I understood value like yeah you
know people are willing to part with a
resource if they're getting something
for it that they value or they see the
value in anyway so then I went to the
ritz-carlton and I said who's the doctor
your hotel I said who are you I said I'm
the doctor to the Mandarin they said you
are and and so one thing led to the
other and I started this house call
service you know San Francisco in the
late 90s and that's that's what kind of
started my career like as accidental is
everything else in my life like super
smart for seeing that because like you
said value people need to feel like
they're getting value and then they will
gladly depart with their money yeah and
you saw that as a missing link at the
five-star hotel the only one the
Mandarin and then he went off and
continued ritz-carlton this is so and so
the but you know I grew up in a kind of
middle upper-middle class my dad was a
surgeon but you know we didn't have like
great wealth and like you know I wasn't
the society set like I was wasn't going
to these balls and private schools I was
public school guy and so like my
experience growing up was very you know
middle upper-middle class whatever lived
in the burbs a little bit but then I had
this window into these people's lives
like where that were you know all sorts
of misol ever tea and I'll use celebrity
and not like movie star celebrity could
be a baseball player could be a
financial celebrity just like a
governor's of celebrity and like just
this concept of power and fame and
whatever that means and whatever that is
but then I was the guy that and you
realize they're just people I love this
picture yeah so I was doing a photo
shoot a new photo of headshot and I had
the photographer in my house I'm like
you know I got this super cool top hat
that I bought at a vintage store so I
want to try that he's like put it on
like I'm like maybe I'll use that
headshot from time to time yeah for a
conference you know instead of like that
again it's more levity than gravity
everyone's always trying to like you
know show you
serious they are and it's just like
these artificial smiles for the camera
or it's like I can do that but everybody
does that like where's the novelty I
mean our eyes are always trained a
novelty yeah you said our minds were
trained enough I'm always trying to do
weird [ __ ] when people take photos yeah
okay so continue so so anyways learning
about the market crashed in 2001
September 11th and like nobody traveled
planes didn't fly hotels were empty
I had a seven doctor business at the
time we had grown from like the Mandarin
to we were serving all sorts of
businesses anybody that saw value that
wanted a doctor available to them like
lickety-split yeah like I was that guy
and and so it was called San Francisco
on-call Medical Group and then all of a
sudden I when the market crashed our
revenue went to zero and I had all these
doctors and nurses and people I'm like
guys you got you know I had to fire
people I had to fire a lot of people and
it was really really hard
yeah I'd never done that and then I
realized that when you're in the free
market like if you take insurance and
there's like an economic hit people yeah
by the time they get laid off and they
lose their insurance like that's like a
year it's not immediate there's like the
long buffer and delay like the medical
economy is generally unaffected by
anything else in the economy because
like it's almost like there that
everybody puts into their they pay their
employer and that or they have Medicare
it's just like it's like a gigantic
buffer for doctors they just don't feel
the shock and that's one of the reasons
why they're disconnected from value if
they do greater they do shitty they're
still full like if you have a store and
you have like cockroaches and bad food
no one's eating there but in medicine if
you say I'm available your fault you're
full as if primary as a specialist you
you know you might not be full you're
trying to hump for business all the time
because you're trying to get doctors
like me to refer to you so what I
realize is like wow I'm in the free
market and this free market is like like
I'm exposed completely to fluctuations
in the market yeah and and so I had to
let people love people go and and you
know I had to retool an organization
that was seven doctors and probably 20
to 20 people down to like two doctors
and and one staff like we we really had
to skinny that up or three doctors and
and it was like got wrenching and I was
like in my 30s I'm like damn I
like me too girl and have kids and I got
like I can't have this instability in my
life and and so that's when I thought
well maybe I'll go to a subscription
model where at least I'm not waiting for
the next visit like when you do the
house call that you get paid for the
visits I'm goes to overhead sum goes to
you and very transactional yeah and so
you know and I was like I want to be in
something that's not transactional yeah
it's like a SAS business it's a
subscription
everybody loves a subscription business
right and so that's when actually it's
one guy had called me who I had seen at
the Mandarin Oriental years earlier so
the movie knew San Francisco I said well
he goes can I join your practice I'm
like at its annual fees like great I'll
sign up so he signed up and he's like a
major guy in the tech world still is and
he loved that I was using email and text
like I was that tip of the spear like
now we're talking about blockchain like
back then it was like hey the guy has
uses email and he texts and he's a
doctor like they don't do that I can
found one you know who does that but to
me it was like you know the shrinking
the distance of communication when
there's anxiety involved is a good thing
for everybody like so I you know anxiety
left over long period of time just with
snowballs it doesn't get better on its
own anxiety always gets worse left
unattended so you know when you have
anxiety about your health you want to
get to a doctor that's gonna help you
get to either I should be worried or I
shouldn't be and if I it which we are
how do we resolve it and so like how do
you shrink the distance of anxiety when
you have it and so that was kind of I
think what this guy saw in me and is
that was my kind of operating system and
that was what I learned from the
Mandarin is like how do you make people
feel good about the process even if it's
not good sometimes these examples that
you've given to us and to to where where
I've been able to read and learn more
about what's going on the subscription
is totally worth it
you're one click away from a doctor and
you're two clicks away from your
connection my network your network what
experts in the world so then it it's
it's totally worth every single dollar
and in these examples like oh my kid
broke his leg we're going to the ER and
you're like
no I'm gonna redirect you to a much
better place for a massive operation
like that right so these types of things
they're life-changing suggestions
they're they're very small things and
one of the interesting things is people
like oh I want to get dr. slain or
private medical that they'll get me the
front of the line right and so that's
like you know I'm a you know as
left-wing liberal as they can be I got
conservative bones in my body I've got
liberal bones but you know I'm more on
the side of the people then the the you
know some version of the elite that
should be better like everyone's equal
in my book so to speak and and so I lost
my train of thought
probably medical yeah so giving these
little recommendations yes so these
little things so what we read there was
is we don't actually cut in the front of
line I feel like that's a little elitist
we actually remove the line and what do
I mean by that so if you're sick and you
call me up and you say hey man I've got
this problem
and you know can you get connect can you
get me in the front of line like how
about I come over to your house and see
you right now
yeah and then I determined that there's
no line to go and here's the problem you
know so but but you know and if I
actually had a ton of anecdotes like
this but if I had enough of them and I
could do a proper study around and I
would probably show that by people
paying and investing in themselves and
their healthcare by hiring somebody like
me or there's a thousand other groups
out there that do it yeah you actually
lower the cost to the system but the
system doesn't care the system actually
like as much as we want to lower cost
the system makes money every time you do
something yes so it's a very
transactional model and there's a moral
hazard
that's infiltrated every aspect of
healthcare the more you do the more you
make so why would I want to do less so
if there's a choice of yeah we're not
sure if we should do this or not like
clinically and and there's evidence is
like in the middle everyone's gonna go
to do something because money is
attached to it if you do nothing there's
no money attached to it and even though
that even though that might be the right
thing to do and I've got a lot of
stories about sometimes and a lot of
people in medicine because it's such a
hard to get in and once you're an you
like don't just stand there doctor do
something you know my philosophies don't
just do something
let's stand there let's just sit in that
uncomfortable place for a minute and
talk about why doing something may
actually be more negative than than
doing nothing like what are the pros and
cons of nothing if I'm here all the time
you know everybody usually wants
something done because they don't feel
like they have an attachment or
connectivity or a continuity to you
after it's been done oh thank you Ron
that must be a timer that is a 15
minutes Wow
yeah we've been yeah we've been going
really hard it's been fun though we've
been covering a lot of good bases so
okay so now how big how big is private
medical notice this in 20 years so I so
yeah so then pragmatical turn into a
subscription service which now we have
off we have three offices in California
and you know 20 21 doctors I think I you
know but we take care of family so we
have pediatricians internal medicine
naturopath gynecology and so I I look at
like health care is like it you know the
family's the fundamental unit of humans
and you know so how do you take take
care of a family so when I think about
medicine medicines pills and you know
all you know hospitals and shots and
surgeries but health is a much bigger
circle around medicine medicines like
this gravitational suck that it draws
you pulls you in but health is like
where you exist mostly and then if
something bad happens or something you
know you wind up there so how do you
keep people away from medicine and in
health and so that's kind of what we do
is we think about you when you're not in
front of us most doctors only think
about you when you're in front of them
and so our role is to think 10 20 years
down the road like I was talking to a
patient this morning and I said look
this issue that you have it doesn't hurt
it doesn't bleed you don't even think
about it but you have a high blood
pressure and you're like 40 I said this
will cause heart attacks strokes and all
sorts of problems for you when you're 60
yeah so like I need to don't ignore this
because it doesn't hurt or like why am i
taking a pill for something that I don't
see like because I'm thinking 20 years
from now I'm not thinking about right
now you are because if you live from the
right now but I've seen this movie
before I've taken care of people that
didn't do their I didn't take care of it
now I'm dealing with strokes and heart
attacks and Candee disease and blindness
and like all these things that are
non-trivial but now you're 65 in you're
kinda screwed
because you just did pay attention so my
job is to mine view because that's not
your you mean I want you to participate
I'm gonna give you all the evidence and
the data and I'm gonna treat you the way
you treat your investments or anything
else that you value in your life I'm
gonna value your health and I'm gonna
think about it in the future so we're
very proactive we're always doing stuff
proactively most of Medicine's reactive
yes and then there's also the founding
of health loop ten years ago so yeah
that also kind of ended up catalyzing a
good amount of of having the strong
connection between these ties of
efficacy in health care well I realized
that here I'm in Silicon Valley and
actually the the brief story you know is
I had a woman in my office with coffee
fever and shortness of breath and she
was pretty sick and she was like 70 and
she had a community-acquired pneumonia I
listened to her lungs I'm like this is a
slam-dunked ammonia it's small you know
here's the antibiotics here's my
cellphone number you know you have a 97%
chance according to the literature of
getting better on these antibiotics but
that's in the 3% chance you don't like
it's could be fatal so like I you need
to call me if you're not doing better
five days later seven days later the
phone rang it was the emergency room it
wasn't her she goes she's here in
respiratory distress she's probably not
gonna make it we're putting on a
ventilator in the intensive care unit
and and my heart sank and I was like
holy smokes
why didn't she call me and then I
thought why didn't I call her and then I
kind of like I left my you to my head
and I went into the universe of like how
did this happen you know I kind of got
very meta to everything and I realized
while I was in the metal and that health
care Kari cares about two things what
was the diagnosis and how much time did
I spend and that's how you put those
things into the thing and you get paid
yeah you have to put codes in when you
bill now I don't do that in my practice
cuz I'm all in for a fee I don't have to
bill yeah things but everybody else says
and I realize but the whole system's
been built on two codes what's the
diagnosis and how much time did I spend
yeah I'm like where's the empathy code
where's the code for how concerned am I
about you
yeah like medically concerned and and so
that's when I was like all this
technology is working against me it's
not working for me so I said I I want to
I want to like build an empathy code and
I want to check in with people to figure
out how they're doing after they've left
here like I don't like no news has gotta
not good news
this digital trust well it's like how do
you create digital empathy how do i how
could so now patients get an email dr.
Splaine wants to check in with you on
the subject line and you're like well my
doctor did what and then you open up the
email there's a link and then it says
hey you're five days into this we know
what time it is I can predict the future
you're because in five days on this
story the movie I've seen the movie
before but I know in five days from now
you're gonna be wondering about these
things and I'm gonna tell you about
those things but everybody worries about
those things because the human operating
system is very predictable and I'm just
really concerned and then I'm asking
them how they're doing so I I tell them
what they need to know and I ask them
how they're doing in well - multiple
choice questions they go into the
algorithm if they trip a wire I get
notification so every day patients are
getting messages dr. st. Jim but I'm not
I'm only getting the ones where they
trip the wire or if they don't check in
so they don't check in I treat
engagement like a vital sign yeah they
have to engage yeah you have their
health which is why I don't like the
words adherence and compliance yeah
because they're very paternalistic and
like bad dog you weren't compliant
engagement it's a participant your own
health its participation and engagement
like we need to use words that are more
maternal and friendly and soft and like
you want to engage in participate but
you don't want to be compliant like
that's like I guess I caught you but I
don't want like there's such a negative
edge around that stuff and so we have
literal studies about how this showing
concern for somebody else's health and
checking in frequently building yeah
let's let's showcase yeah so so we did a
study with anthem over the last 18
months where we did patients on health
flu patients would be randomized to
health loop or that's not this one but
but this is a yeah this one okay at
multi multi Center multi special
orthopedic surgery hip and knee
surgeries only so people that we're
gonna get a major hip and a knee
replacement you were either randomized
to be put on health loop or just to go
to the way it's always been going so and
the way that I was you see your doctor
and then two weeks later be able to
follow it is it maybe and you make some
calls if you know so so this is like a
guided tour through your your your story
on health loop or not and what we found
is that we felt like we could detect
things early if someone said I got a
little cramp in my calf after surgery
that's so that's a blood clot until
proven otherwise but most people think
well I had surgery I probably got a
cramp
and then what happens that blood clot
breaks off and it goes in their lungs
they have a pulmonary embolus and they
wind up in the ICU and they cost
millions of dollars and they sometimes
don't live Wow or they have a little
redness or they have a little fever and
they think that's normal but it's the
beginning of an infection so by usually
healthy you have these leading
indicators or bad things that are about
to happen like I can't prevent it from
happening per se but I can prevent it
from spiraling out of control by
catching it early and course correcting
and intervening so what this study
showed over and by the way the
engagement on health loop over time is
like 78 80 percent meaning that every
time a patient gets a thing they click
on it they read it they answer the
questions so imagine if you're like a
tech company or software company and you
send out a mass mailing like success is
2% if 2% of people open up your thing
you'll call that a success 5% slike
amazing 10% is you one we're getting 78%
over the course of a year people check
in a year later we're building trust
we're showing them that we care for them
this is that this helps them participate
and engage but we actually lowered the
cost six hundred fifty six dollars per
case I mean that's like non-trivial and
we this makes so much sense because
you're reaching out to them more
frequently what's proactive it's
proactive they're actually able to say
how they feel or what's going on with
them and then like you said you're able
to prevent the onset of further issues
because you're actually communicating
with communication is the fundamental
unit if you do so everyone's building IT
infrastructure I'm like you know what
I'm done with that we need to
communication architecture that's what
we need we need to communication
architect to come in and say how should
we communicate and so this is like
version 1 of a communication
architecture around a complex system
that does not value or pay for
communications we only value and pay for
what's the disease and how much time did
you spend
there's no after that there's no payment
for communication it's like so what to
me is like we just pay for outcomes and
so this is um you know UCSF did a study
will patients give you you know
information and so this is like your
patients will complete information six
months later at 55% patients are telling
you how they're doing they they are act
but
they're telling their doctor they're not
doing some third party company correct
this is their doctor owns the
information they want to get the
insights about them or health the pit
then the doctors want to know how the
patients are doing like if you ask a
patient would you like the best outcome
the fastest for this the answer is a
hundred percent yes there's no patient
no I want a bad outcome if you ask
doctors would you like your patients to
get the best outcome the fastest it's of
course so here you have the two main
actors in healthcare the doctor and the
patient they both want the same thing
but everyone's conspiring to not let
that happen in the weirdest ridiculous
ways because no one's built this health
care system it is a patch on top of a
patch so it's a quilt of bad ideas
trying to fix bad ideas that masquerade
is good ideas that it's like
whack-a-mole you fix it here at a
creates problem over there so there's no
one's like looking at the broader thing
70% relative reduction in 30-day
admissions yeah so you have surgery and
use health loop there's a there's a like
a large chance that you'll get you won't
have to go back to the hospital so
exactly these things are like it's
almost as though people cease they don't
believe it
they're like no way and so you know
medical doctors are skeptical
administrators are at the hospital
skeptical they just don't believe it and
it's health flu purchased by hospital by
hospitals and doctors right now but now
we have insurance companies saying hey
this saves money so there may be a
moment where insurance companies say hey
we're gonna you have to use this like
this is something that yeah it's better
to use yeah exactly why would you not
use it tell me why you're not and the
reason is and this is crazy is that we
make money on readmissions yeah we
actually make money on reading mentions
it's crazy dude it's crazy so but what
Obama did like them or not is yeah this
is an actually study this is the super
interesting study which I want to get to
is Obama said hey your your income
should reflect your outcomes that's that
that's the if somebody was gonna
simplify Obama care yes get insurance
coverage but on the other side of it
like you know that's just like covered
not covered but underneath it it's we're
gonna change the system to create you
get paid if you get a good outcome so
right but how do you know how do you get
a good outcome compliance adherence
patient leaves how do you know
yeah there's no communication
architecture yeah there's got to be
communication architecture to solve that
problem this was one where at MD
Anderson we
the first ones we did people that are
just told her there they've got
stage-four came and they got cancer you
got to go through the pet the the PET
scan to find out what stage it is so
these people are about to come out of
this scan and be told how bad it is or
how bad it isn't but it's like super
high stakes exam as anxious as a moment
of your life oh you're gonna get going
into the machine to tell you what's on
the other couple months or year a couple
years they're gonna yeah you have to
live or or you need three surgeries and
radiation and chemo like on the other
side of this scan all that information
exists yeah so so they found that a lot
of people that would go into this
scanner they would have like super high
anxiety and they'd have a panic attack
and they wouldn't they wouldn't do it
because they just couldn't yeah they had
a freakout and they thought this was
gonna give them some pain they didn't
understand what this was all incomes all
so what we decided to do the two guys
that do that work the machine that the
two doctors we said what if we scheduled
people two weeks and by the way when
they freaked out
they they they don't get the scan then
they got to get a mental health visit a
physical they got to come back for the
scan two weeks later and then they got
to get sedated they need a ride home so
the cost goes way up if you have a
freaked out yeah yeah and you didn't get
the answer and someone could have filled
that spot that like you wait there's all
sorts of inefficiencies for the freak
out like that happen all in the supply
chain of like scheduling and everything
so we said what if we just had patients
in the run-up to the scan health loop
we'll just we're not gonna ask him how
they're due what we'll ask him a few
questions but we'll show them what it is
well have patients that have gone
through and explained to them it's not
that bad you know and we'll just we'll
communicate with the guys that they're
gonna meet when they show up these like
daily videos and just education and the
literacy rate went way up and the amount
of people that freaked out went way down
it's because they understood they got
educated the answer is education it
always is and education has to come with
communication yeah and so you're
messaging them ahead of time prior to
their PET scan like right so what we say
we will we've been to the future we know
it's gonna be used so used to be only
21% used to know what ionizing rate
Asian is now 66% do etc so you there B
so when you increase the education you
decrease the freak outs freak oh yeah
which are inefficiencies in healthcare
that's so interesting because you can do
this and not just well it's an utter an
operation you can do before now there's
a pre in the post and and like this has
been like this crazy window on things
that I would have never known or thought
about but health loop has given me a
much more bigger perspective on how one
little efficiency through communication
solves nine other and that everyone's
trying to solve that inefficiency with a
better scheduling system or like make
the patient pay a little bit more or
like they've got it but no just I can
communicate you know Kate yeah you
you're really nailing it with health
loop I love it
and I think this synergized with like
patients like me that community as well
as kind of like a bio trillion like
organizations that are leveraging
biometrics plus machine learning to
really figure out there's a lot of
learning all of these things jam-packed
together with what health loops doing as
well is just gonna be an amazing
progress in health care and I'm so
excited
moving forward with it I want to touch
on just a couple of these other things
on the way out
so tincture health people can subscribe
and well it's it's just a publication
that I created for it's an ideas but I
fund itself funded and basically
tincture dot IO is what it is and it's
basically I get all these really smart
people to write little essays about the
ideas they have about health care and
the way I frame it is is if you walk
into a big warehouse and there's
flashlight shining on various walls
you'll only see what the flashlight
shines on you will not know what the
whole room looks like is it dark until
you get to a place where there's light
but if you took all the flashlights that
were shining on something and you put
them in the center of the room you may
light up the room and then you could see
the whole thing and then you could
starts thinking differently about how to
solve that problem and so I'm trying to
illuminate this gigantic room of
healthcare because everyone's always
looking at the one thing that they know
and and they and there's not a place to
go where you can see other things that
are or adjacent orthogonal parallel meta
that it will just make you think
different about the way you've been
thinking about the thing that's right in
front of you forever so teachers a place
to go expand your mind and and and then
you can if you're a good writer and
you've got a good idea go but you can't
talk about your company and you can't
talk about yourself this is an idea like
it's an ideas meet each other
you know and then this is not only go
t-shirt I own go receive the great
newsletter that's going out about this
with all these great ideas but also I
just definitely want to touch on I'm eat
real as well you're going out to
cafeterias and schools and hospitals and
this is this is also really important
making sure that the food's like you
said it's not food-like substances it's
actual foods actual food and food by the
way it comes from three things sunlight
soil and water if it didn't if it didn't
come from that it's not food it's a food
like substance yeah right and so like
real food is real food we know where it
comes from water it's just three
ingredients yeah that's it yeah I made a
little bit of tender loving care you
know in the environment but it doesn't
come from a factory it just doesn't if
it does it's not food it's a food like
substance and so like LEED certification
you know says this building is like
sustainable and it was you know solar or
whatever so we're trying to build like a
lead like certification so it's a trust
mark certification for organizations
that serve food
so is this restaurant is this cafeteria
at school is this hospital are they
serving toxic substances or are they
serving real food yes and so we want to
start highlighting those with Stanford
the university undergrad is certified
the Grand Ole Opry is certified UCSF
hospital systems certified right the
plant cafe got our Platinum
certification show so there are pools
whips heads of school they can in the
East Bay we're gonna start certifying
schools so we have like 600
certifications but we're like we're
nonprofit we're under the radar so if
you have any interest in this and you
want to help out like we'll have links
in the bio yeah please check it out and
help out spread the word it's it's I
just feel like I can't change any
individual behavior on a person I can't
change the billions of dollars of Coke
and Pepsi and all these big companies
are spending but what I can do is like
go to the places where people eat and
talk to those people the chefs and like
tap into their moral obligation to not
poison their students their patients
their employees or their customers yeah
it's better for the collective yeah so a
couple couple quick ease on the way-out
a simulation i'm a couple of questions
that we really like to ask just the
first one gene what do you think about
what's going on with wealth inequality
there's a lot of concentration of wealth
from the very very top couple percent of
people and then
bottom layer is kind of slowly coming up
as well but might a much slower rate
than the top is what do you think's
happening with that as well as
globalization with the United States
collaborating with China Russia
progressing well I think that the second
question first is the global economy is
so interconnected that doing a trade war
about a metal or a thing like nobody
realizes how many people are involved in
that metal it said you're not just
you're not affecting just it's all
interconnected now so that you can't
take a very simplistic view of the world
you have to have a nuanced multi-level
view and so you know anything you do is
gonna have pros and cons and some of
them are gonna be totally unknown to you
like you're not gonna know it there'll
be an emergent property out of complex
systems develop emergent properties and
so when you start tinkering with complex
systems you get all these emergent
properties that there's a whack-a-mole
so you know that's why you would like to
think about what you're doing and like
really talk to stakeholders so so I
think that globalization and inequality
and so like I have a front-row seat
candidly to a lot of wealth like I'm not
that wealthy myself but and I feel like
to some degree once you have lots of
wealth you know you're either generous
influent philanthropic or it becomes
just a game and whatever you have you
want more because more is better and and
there's a lot of people out there that
that you know they just want more and
and they donate they're not they're
unaware candidly of all the people that
don't have anything because they never
really in those circles and those people
in those certain like the masses in
general they never get behind that gate
to see what's in that gate so yeah you
can watch pimp my ride and you can you
can watch the lifestyles of the rich and
famous
and you get like a micro window into it
but the truth is is the people in the
world I calm the vagaries like they just
have to you know they got to get their
food they got to go to the bathroom they
got a they go to their job it's like
life is just a series of events that
come at you and you have to like deal
with them right that's all life is too
much people have to do that too they
have the same things just with the big
gold-plated or not right it's still the
same food you have to eat is in bathroom
you have to use or the same problem with
your girlfriend's son wife mother like
everyone has the say like to me everyone
is the same issues but but money is
money is corroding I think
like I think we the people at the bottom
have it better than they ever have I
still think it's not good enough right I
think that that like how much money does
a person need at the end of the day how
much can one person really have and if
you have billions and billions of
billions like you should be you should
take that that that privilege and and
and show others what you can and and be
that generous precisely the people that
are rich and cheaper unlucky like the
the unfortunate they could do so much
yeah and and you know and I think that
I'm starting to see a lot more people
starting to come to that realization
because wealth is concentrated so fast
and in such a short period of time we
gain a lot of meaning and purpose from
helping others yeah humanity is about
people and helping people is I think the
most rewarding thing one can do yes
alright what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world is a child
laughing is this is the laughter of a
child the pure joy to me that is the
most beautiful thing well I I could just
watch the little kids giggling and
laughing over the silliest things all
day long it is it is a it is like
imminent joy eminent joy for me to watch
that no go doubt was recently teaching
us like you should go do an experiment
where you just go and watch children and
watch them giggle Washington have
happiness and it's inherent and only
later does culture close the aperture
well I think I think that laughter in
general is and comedy is is is kind of
the the art of absurdity so it's things
that are funny if someone says I was
just kidding that was a joke like then
it wasn't funny
right if you have to disclaim that it
was a joke then it wasn't a joke right
then it was like sarcasm or an opinion
masquerading as whatever a joke but but
true comedy is when you when there's
something absurd and it's like so my
daughter was reading me ad-libs this
morning before I came here and she was a
giggling I just like I just want to stay
and why should I watch the giggles you
know I was like god that's so much fun
stay and watch the giggles stay and
watch the giggles doctor saline are we
alone in the cosmos you know it depends
on what you mean by alone and it depends
like what you mean by cosmos right Abbie
first we don't know it's cosmos
it's ever-expanding its contracting it's
you know in humans our version of
intelligence as a carbon-based saying
with sentience E and a bind in a complex
system and like there could be other
versions of complex systems that are not
carbon-based that have some like
functionality that they do something
that is that intelligence is that alone
like so I think that I think there's a
version of everything like we're one
version but there's a version of
everything out there and and you know I
like this version because I guess we
have to write it's all we got
so I don't I don't think we're alone but
I don't think think there's aliens with
like big heads and eyeballs that you
know are in flying saucers and stuff
like I think that that life is an
interesting thing to define I think
complex systems and I study a lot of
complex systems and and biologic systems
are just complex systems and so is super
complex you know but so source or rock
formations are the river flows through
you know yeah it's like that's a whole
complex in the way that all works thanks
geologists yeah so so I think that I
think that we're not alone when we're
with each other and and when we're by
ourselves were not with each other so
we're alone but globe but but but
cosmologically speaking you know we're
made out of Stardust like light turns
into plants that we eat that makes us go
right and so where did that light come
from it came out so we are of the cosmos
we're not sweet I don't view ourselves
as like we're a separate thing that
exists in it
we're of it totally everything's of it
what are the brothers and sisters though
so we are for now I mean yeah so how
about do you think there's a designer to
the universe ooh what a great question I
think that what people say designer it
implies a person or a thing or some
entity like a God or somebody sitting on
a chair or somebody like you know with
it with a calculator I think the
universe is exactly the way it's
supposed to be and I think it's all
emergent and I don't think that somebody
like said okay radius of a carbon
electron
outside of the proton needs to be this
distance which creates the properties of
water and then water will create the
properties of life you know I just think
that this is like a grand experiment
happening in front of our eyes and I
just think properties of the universe
have manifested emergently and they will
continue to do so yeah George laying
this such a pleasure holy cat we covered
some ground we did yes and you are very
multidisciplinary man not just in health
but also in society and emotion and in
understanding humans and I really
appreciate that so much and technology
as well and we have a lot more to unpack
on another show with you I'm really
looking forward to that thanks hey
joining us with pleasure yeah thanks it
was great learning about everything man
and I really love that lesson from from
Kenya and I really loved you know what
health loop is doing right now and it oh
my god panic attack before the PET scan
because yeah you're gonna learn that on
the way out there's so many cool things
we unpacked guys if you had a good time
definitely share this content with two
other people they'll share with two
people just go teach people what you
learned from here also go and create
what this content don't just consume go
make a blog go make a video start a
company in space go and execute cool
things into the world also join us on
patreon we need to continue supporting
the studio expanding growing the team
growing the impact going to reach
getting to the football stadium so let's
get there together thank you everyone
for tuning in thanks Ron for producing
the show much love everyone peace
you